hi guys i'm Abbey Sharpe welcome to
Abbey's Kitchen! Today's what I eat in a
day youtuber review is sponsored by
Function of Beauty and I'm going to be
reviewing Derek's Simnett of Simnett
Nutrition. Now before we do, I want to
tell you about this awesome new haircare
line I've been using from Function of
Beauty. Now I have always been pretty
picky about any beauty products that I
use especially now that I'm pregnant,
and I love that this line has no
parabens or sulfates and is a hundred
percent vegan and cruelty free. So this
is really simple, you basically just fill
out a two-minute quiz about your hair
type, your hair goals, and any personal
preferences that you have and you also
get to choose your color and fragrance.
They even print your name on the bottle
I mean how cute is this? So as a blonde my
hair does tend to go a little bit brassy
if I wash it too much so that was a
priority for me. I also was looking to
fix split ends, strengthen, volumize and
add shine. So they sent me their
specially formulated purple shampoo plus
a daily conditioner and a leave-in
treatment for added moisture. I also
opted for the peach scent and I have to
tell you like my hair smells really
really good. It's also got some nice
shine and some strength even after
coloring, so I'm really happy with the
results. They also have a hair mask and
serum and everything is customized and
can be added on to any order if you're
looking for a new haircare product that
uniquely fits your needs. Check out the
link in my bio to get 20% off your first
order. Also a big reminder that this
video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only and it's not
meant to diagnose or prescribe any way
of eating so you should always speak to
a registered dietician and doctor about
your specific needs. Ok so, folks, a little background on
Derrick. Now Derrick is a plant-based
certified nutritional practitioner who's
graduated from the Institute of holistic
nutrition. Now because this is a question
that has come up a lot before, I do want
to quickly clarify the difference
between a nutritionist and a registered
dietitian. So a dietitian is a regulated
nutrition professional that has gone
through extensive university education
and training in nutritional sciences. A
nutritionist can really be anyone since
this is not a regulated term. But
somebody who identifies as a
nutritionist could be your next-door
neighbor with no nutrition education or
it could be somebody with a PhD in
nutrition sciences. There are some great
comprehensive nutrition programs and
there are ones that you could easily
complete on a weekend online so really
it's like comparing apples to oranges. So
obviously there are great discrepancies
here. There are amazing nutritionists and
there are sketchy ones so just a heads
up that if you see somebody use this
title it's best to ask a little bit more
about their credentials and education
first. Now in contrast you cannot call
yourself a registered dietician unless
you've completed a minimum of a four
year undergrad in nutritional science, a
two year combined master's degree or a
one year internship, then you have to
pass the National Board Exam and in a
lot of cases you need annual continuing
education credits to keep yourself up to
date.
You're also regulated by a college to
ensure that we, you know, maintain our
oath to do no harm.
Now nutritionist is not a regulated term
so if you run into a problem with
malpractice or poor advice there's
really little that you can do about it
and there's very little preventing that
person from giving that advice that is
why you may see some not-so-great
nutritionists talk about really sketchy
unproven miracle supplements or diets
and you won't see that same enthusiasm
necessarily from registered dietitians.
And it's because we are really committed
to evidence-based practice. Having said
that, there are lots of amazing awesome
evidence-based nutritionists and
holistic practitioners out there who are
not registered dietitians but, like I
said, you definitely need to do your
research and personally I know there
seems to be a lot of professional
competition between these two parties
but I actually see a lot of value from
learning from one another and actually
working collaboratively as a bit of a
team. So like I said I'm not bashing
nutritionists, there are amazing
nutritionists out there giving amazing
advice, but it is something that you need
to of course do your research on. Ao on
that note let's dive in with Derek's
first breakfast.
Ao it's about mid-morning now and I
haven't had anything to eat today. I
usually like to try and come to my
workouts fasted if I can and sometimes I
work out too late in the day where it's
not possible but today is one of those
days where I can, so I'm pretty sure it's
gonna be a good workout. I always feel so
good when I work out fairly early in the
day and fasted. Now in terms of
exercising fasted or not, there is some
research to support fasting for improved
aerobic performance. So the idea is that
since you're fasted you'll have lower
levels of stored carbohydrates aka
glycogen so they will deplete rather
quickly and as a result you may use more
fat to fuel your exercise. Now keep in
mind that this is not for everyone and
often it really only works for people if
they're exercising early in the morning
so that they're not starving by the time
that they work out you know having a
little bit of fuel in the tank can often
give you the energy that you need to get
you through a hard session, so always
listen to your body and find a routine
that ultimately works best for you but
it seems like this is working for for
Derek so amazing. Now of course if you
have certain medical conditions like
diabetes, then it is extremely important
that you speak to your doctor before
trying fasted exercise. Let's see what
else he has to say. So I've just had water today and some beetroot crystals.
Okay so there's nothing really wrong
with taking beetroot crystals before a
workout but, like he said, you definitely
do not need it. There is some research
that has shown that the nitric oxide in
beetroot may increase vo2 max also time
to exhaustion, improve blood pressure, and
overall oxygen delivery to the muscles.
However, the research is definitely mixed
in this area and we really do need more
information specifically around dose and
overall impact.
I remember there used to be a commercial on TV I think it was a quaker commercial and it was an old Scottish guy and he was like
"oats thick enough that you can stand on" And, yeah. I have to agree. I like them that way too.
So I've got some pumpkin seeds that are
going on there as well
Alright. So there is the post workout meal. The old green smoothie and oatmeal combo. Absolutely love this
Okay so this looks incredible. I mean I
love that he added banana and dates to
his oatmeal to sweeten it naturally
without added sugar, while providing that
slow burning energy, and the smoothie
brings a nice helping of veggies with
the kale, some healthy fats from the flax,
and protein with the protein powder. He
did make an interesting comment, however,
about turmeric and led that I definitely
want to address but first let's hear
what he has to say. okay so there is some
So basically a lot of the powdered turmeric thats coming into the United States , and presumably North America, has lots of led in it.
Okay so there is some research that has shown that turmeric produced in certain countries, mainly
India and Bangladesh, contain higher
levels of lead chromate, which is an
additive used to enhance its yellow
color. Using fresh turmeric is ultimately
a really great idea to avoid this
altogether, like he said, but you can also
look for turmeric sourced from elsewhere
if you want the convenience and are concerned
Cheers to that Derrick I love
that you are calling that out and if you
want to hear my personal thoughts on
food combining we've got two videos here
that I'm gonna link to. But, Derrick, thank
you for fighting the good fight with me.
Let's take a look at breakfast number
two. okay so this is an example of
So this is just a big bowl of fruit. As you can see, I grabbed an orange, we got a nice ripe mango here, as well as a nice chopped banana and just some hemp seeds on top.
Okay so this is an example of Derrick eating before a workout. Although
it is just simple sugars mainly from
fruit with a little bit of the protein
and the healthy fats from the hemp hearts,
this can actually be really helpful for
people who are sensitive to eating a lot
before a workout and it can give you
that fast digesting energy to fuel your
workout. Let's take a look at what he's
eating after exercising.
Just gonna make this like a smoothie bowl just kind of helped me to
slow down my eating so I don't just gulp
it all down really quickly and there's a
few things to chew in there so it helps
with the digestion as well. So I just got
some fresh blueberries on there and this
granola here by Engine two. I also have
already talked a lot about the idea
between eating a smoothie bowl and
drinking a smoothie through a straw when
I reviewed Mona Vands tips on how to
reduce bloating, so if you haven't
already watched that video definitely
check it out right here.
But yeah the smoothie Bowl looks super
delicious. We've got lots of
color, we've got some protein from the
protein powder, we've got some healthy
fats in the flax, that granola looks
amazing, I would like to get my hands on
it as well. And I definitely also agree I
like some little crunchy bits on top of
my smoothie bowl as well. So looks pretty
good.
So today since we're going to be outside for a little while, I'm not sure how long its going to be until eat again
I decided to have a quick smoothie before I left the house today. So its a slimmed down version of the post workout smoothie I usually have
So its just one banana, a cup of frozen berries, one pitted medjool date I had a tablespoon and a
half or two tablespoons of ground
flaxseed in there as well. A scoop of viva life protein powder and I also used a few grams of creatine.
So for liquid I just used water. I put a small handful of kale in there as well.
So this is a great tip for those of you who maybe struggle with planning your eating for the day
if you're not sure how busy your day is
gonna be or or you aren't sure when
you're gonna be able to eat next,
I do recommend having a small meal or a
snack before you leave the house to just
tide you over. Otherwise, I do find that
we tend to get ravenously hungry and
this is typically when less mindful food
decisions get made.
But again looks like a very balanced
smoothie, we've got protein, we've got
lots of fruit, we've got some veggies in
there too. Looks delicious. So let me know give you
my overall thoughts on breakfast. In
general I think that Derick is doing a
great job of getting in some healthy
fruits, veggies, fat, and protein. Probably
my only criticism here is that I'd love
to see some more non drinkable
breakfasts, though I get that it's a
total convenience thing and he's
especially as like a pre or post-workout.
So if it works for him it works for me.
Let's move on to lunch.
Some hummus, some tofu - smoked tofu -
this stuff is so good, and then avocado
just on some toast. We get this
bread, it's like super fresh and it is so
so tasty and you can see it's just like
really really clean ingredients. Nothing
too crazy added to it. Oh so I also went
and put some kimchi on top of it and
then some pea shoots as well and also
some hot sauce. That looks so so good
okay.
So here he's got a great source of
complex carbohydrates from the bread,
we've got some plant-based protein from
the smoked tofu, and a little from the
hummus, and of course some healthy fats
from the avocado and I also loved the
kimchi on top and the naturally
fermented bread. I mean these are all
really great for gut health so - yes please!
I got three different tacos. I think I got the barrio, the tulum, and the baja taco.
oh my gosh
I am always down for tacos and I love
that more restaurants are offering vegan
options without necessarily completely
getting rid of some animal-based options
either. You know, I just feel like it
allows flexibility and that way
everybody can find something that they
like. Now he didn't mention what protein
he has on his tacos but it looks like
one has tofu and maybe other has like
vegan chicken. There may be some black
beans on the other one but I can't
really say for sure. Either way so great
to see that he's making sure that he's
getting adequate protein from a variety
of sources. Also tacos are so great
because you get lots of veggies in there,
you get your protein, you get your
healthy fats from the guac, and your carbs
in the tortilla. So basically a perfectly
balanced meal and I am totally craving
Mexican right now. I'm quarantined I
gotta make my own damn tacos. Let's take
a look at lunch three.
We got the verde bowl. So beautiful and colourful. Theres green rice, chopped kale, lentils, sweet potato, tahini, avocado
watermelon radish. These things are so
cool. Also cucumber,
pickled shallots, shaved carrots, pepitas, hemp seeds, and sprouts
thats my kind of bowl. So we also got some almond butter on toast. Some almond butter,
local berry preserves, coconut yogurt, and blueberries.
oh my gosh that is a super yummy looking
bowl and I love that he's got some
lentils in there for plant-based protein,
we got sweet potato and rice for our
complex carbs, as well as from the
lentils and then we've got a variety of
beautiful colorful veggies. I also
noticed that he pays attention to making
sure he gets a variety of colors in
which of course helps to make sure that
you're getting a variety of nutrients.
Also that almond butter toast looks like
a great idea just to sneak in some extra
protein and healthy fats and also it
like looks so delicious.
Lets talk about my overall thoughts on lunch. I am definitely a fan of Derek's lunches here.
I mean he's not afraid to try different
foods and eat meals that will keep him
full for hours. I actually find his
lunches to be really well-rounded and
just generally super delicious looking.
It makes vegan food look so so
appealing. I also love that he's getting
a variety of fats from the hemp seeds,
tahini and avocado and he makes sure to
mix it up in terms of protein by using
tofu, beans, lentils, and meat alternatives.
So great, so tasty. Let's move on to dinner.
I'm probably gonna make a stir
fry it's pretty much what I make like
five nights out of the week. it's just so
easy to make, it so quick you can use up
like leftovers really easily which I
have here and yeah it's really easy to
put like a whole bunch of healthy stuff
into and to make it tasty. So it's really
nothing to lose there. So I've got this
pot of rice and lentils which I cooked
up last night and some veggie broth so
I'm gonna put that on the stove and heat
that up and I just added some more
veggie broth to it because the rice
looked kind of dry.
So dinner's looking all right we got
some carbs from the rice, there's a
little bit of protein in the lentils
that are in there but not a whole lot,
and then all the nutrients from all the
veggies but we definitely need to add
some more protein to this. All right so
you can always count on a can of black
beans for some good protein. One thing
that I like to do to make really tasty
sauces or at least give me like a
starting point when I'm making sauces, is
to hit on three different flavors and
those flavors are sweet, salty, and tangy.
So for sweet today we're using a pitted
medjool date, for the salty component I'm
going to be using some tamari, and then
for tangy today I'm gonna be using this
apple cider vinegar. We've got some nice
tahini here, some Lebanese tahini, some
grainy mustard this really helps the
fats and the water that we're gonna be
adding to this kind of emulsify. You
get a little bit everything in here.
Really good. Heck yeah thats a good bowl right there.
wow that looks like a really
satisfying meal and I love that it's
really so colorful and it's a ton of
different nutrient-dense foods in it.
There is a lot of good stuff going on so
we've got loads of veggies, plus carbs
from rice, we've got protein in the
lentils and beans, and healthy fats with
the tahini sauce and avocado. I mean a
stir-fry like this is such a great way
to use up extra ingredients like he
talked about I will just say that I
noticed he doesn't seem to cook with oil
which is becoming a theme with a lot of
whole food vegans that I review. So if
you're interested in my thoughts in the
no oil trend definitely check out this
video right here that I just recently
posted on my youtube channel. Now I also
want to flag that if you're watching
this and you think that you've prepare
all of those veggies that every single
meal to be healthy that is not true.
Of course most people do not get enough
vegetables but there is a lot of prep
going on here with all those
different vegetable components so I just
want people to know that you don't have
to become a professional sous chef
chopping up vegetables all day long to
have a balanced diet. I mean I'm so glad
that this works for Derek but I totally
acknowledge that for most of us, myself
included as a busy mompreneur, that it's
just not realistic to have to cut up
all of those vegetables for every single
meal. Let's take a look at meal two.
So I dont know if any of you guys know about this, its called natto and its basically like a
fermented soybean. It's good yeah it's a
great source of vitamin k2 it's like
highest source of vitamin k2 the plant
kingdom. Again totally solid looking
bowl here and while I find a lot of
these YouTubers bowls very large in size
but lacking in substance this guy seems
to know how to build a better bowl. We've
got loads of colorful vegetables, protein
from the tofu and leftover tempeh, a
little fat from the tahini, some
slow-burning carbs from the whole grains,
lots of good stuff again. There are a lot
of veggies to have to prepare which
probably feels not so realistic for most
people.
Plus the no oil theme is definitely
alive and well but I will, like I said,
you need to watch the whole video to
watch me unpack that. I also want to talk
about natto which, while slimy, is really
nutritious particularly a great source
of vitamin K like he said. Now there are
actually two main types of vitamin K -  k1
and k2. Vitamin k1 is found in
plant-based foods like leafy green
vegetables, Brussels sprouts, broccoli and
spinach. It's the main source of vitamin
K in the diet, but vitamin k2 is actually
usually microbial sourced. Meaning it
comes from products that utilize
different bacteria for production, like
cheese or yogurt, or in this case natto,
which is what Derek is trying out here.
So briefly. It's also found in certain
animal products and is produced by our
gut bacteria. Now both are great to get
into the diet and I am happy to see
Derek show his viewers food that is
maybe not so well known. Let's see how it tastes.
I think we should do a decent bite
oh my god look at how long it stretches for. Not my favourite.
I am not surprised they
didn't love it I mean I think with a lot
of these strongly flavored foods like
natto it may be best to incorporate it
with other flavors and maybe not right
off the spoon but also the slime factor
yeah that would put me off too. So I
totally get that it was not a hit with
his buddies. Okay let's close things off
with meal three.
Tofu and with some
veggies and hash browns as well so for
the scrambled tofu basically I'm gonna
do is get about half of this huge chunk
of tofu crumble it up and I'm just gonna
add some seasoning. So usually I would
use you know like turmeric and onion
powder, garlic powder, and a few things
but I don't have all those here in this
kitchen because it's not my home. So I'm
gonna be using this. I just got this from
Trader Joe's the other day and so when
they recommended it and it's just like a
sort of you can see the vegan chicken
list seasoning all right so there is
breakfast for dinner
I also added oh geez, it's fallen off.
Its fine. Keep rolling. I also added a bagel.
This is like everything bagel from
Trader Joe's saw these the other day and
they were they smelled so good, they were
so cheap so I had to have it. So I put
some greens on the plate and then I
added the stir-fry with the lentils and
their romanesco broccoli and
everything on there and then just some
of that tahini sauce that I made.
I love breakfast for dinner and unlike a lot of people's breakfasts, Derick has made a
point to ensure that there's actually a
lot of vegetables in his dinner version.
so I like that I'm seeing
carbs here of course with the potatoes
and the bagel, we've got protein with the
tofu and the lentils, lots of fiber rich
veggies, and some fat with a tahini
dressing. Not a lot of fat again since he
doesn't cook with oil, so it doesn't
surprise me that his carb portions need
to be as large as they are to help him
feel satisfied. So if he wanted to cut
back on portions and not have to eat so
much but still feel satiated, he may want
to just add a little bit more fat in his
cooking or if
it's not for him maybe throw some
avocado in there or a little bit more of
those healthy fats from nuts, seeds
things like that. Okay let's talk about
my overall thoughts on dinner. Generally
speaking, Dericks meals have a lot of
variety and good nutrition. I love how he
incorporates different colorful veggies
into his dishes shows us that you can be
using plant-based proteins in a variety
of different ways and makes cooking more
of like a dump it and don't worry about
it exercise than having to follow a
recipe to a tee.
I get that the whole stir fry thing may
be a little bit repetitive for people
but at least he's getting in a variety
of vegetables protein sources and carbs
in his dinners and it's also a great way
to use up any leftovers. Now let's talk
about Derek's overall nutrition. Number
one are his meals balanced? Well based on
his most recent what I eat in a day I would
definitely say that his meals are
relatively balanced and nutrient-dense.
On average he's getting about 2680
calories per day, 60% of which is from
carbs, 24% from fat, and 16% from protein.
Although these do fit within the
recommended macronutrient distribution
and he seems to be doing great with them,
others who are working out at this level
may potentially benefit from a little
bit more protein. I also find some of his
meals to be a little bit repetitive but
he does try to use different ingredients
even though maybe the type of meal is
similar. So I am ultimately totally cool
with that.
Also I'm nitpicking but his dinners do
seem to be a little bit large in
comparison with the rest of the day
which doesn't necessarily make the most
sense for most people considering his
training is happening usually earlier on.
So if he's feeling really really hungry
by dinner and meaning to have that huge
meal to kind of satisfy him for the day,
it might be a good idea to add a little
bit more fat to his cooking or boost up
the protein to evening meal to increase
the satiety factor without adding so
much bulk. Now is Derek missing out on
any major in nutrients in his diet? Well
Derek is vegan and therefore avoids any
kind of animal products. With that being
said Derek is doing an excellent job
making sure that he's still getting in
adequate nutrition from a variety of
foods he's getting a nice variety of
protein from tofu, almond butter, nut,
seeds, lentils, beans, meat alternatives
and plant
based protein powder. He's definitely
getting in more than enough fiber from
whole grains, vegetables, pulses, rice,
fruit, etc. I mean this is actually a very
high fiber diet. For most people it may
be too high and very likely to cause
digestive issues but if this is the way
he's kind of used to eating it's also
very possible that his gut has adjusted
to the excessive load.
now although Derrick is getting enough
fat from his diet technically I would
encourage him to try to get a better
variety of fats into his diet besides
relying on just a few fat rich foods
like tahini for example he could add a
little bit of oil to salads or
stir-fries eat other fat rich foods like
olives and other nuts and seeds maybe
throw in some more avocado etc. Again I
am just reviewing three days of his diet
so he may be eating these things on
other days but we do know that the best
thing we can do with the fat in our diet
is to get a variety of fat since each
oil and fat provides a unique fatty acid
profile and we really want to try to hit
all of the fats that we can. Now all of his
meals are packed with colorful fruits
and vegetables provide amazing
antioxidants and nutrients so I'm not
really concerned about micronutrients.
He didn't actually mention taking any
supplements in these videos which you
know I do prefer influencers to
regularly disclose but in addition to of
course b12, he may also benefit from a
vegan omega-3 supplement with DHA. Yes I acknowledge that he's getting omega
3's from the flaxseed and the hemp
hearts that he consumes but these foods
contain ALA which is not as well
utilized by the body. Some ALA does get
converted into EPA and DHA but
admittedly in small amounts so therefore
a supplement may actually be really
beneficial. Now are there any problematic
claims or assumptions on his channel? For
the most part I'm very happy with
Derek's videos and the lifestyle that he
promotes. I will say he does use the word
clean to describe ingredients and I
think it's best to like steer clear of
that type of wording and verbiage if we
can. Also, like I mentioned, I notice he
doesn't use any oil while he's cooking
and he actually has a whole entire video
discussing this philosophy.
According to Derek, he doesn't use any
oil in his cooking because he chooses to
avoid processed oils and his rationale
is really because processed oils are very
calorically dense but lack nutrition.
Therefore he prefers to get his fats
from foods that give him a wide range of
nutrients. Now I can definitely agree
that oils are very calorie dense, meaning
you get a lot of calories in a small
serving, however this does not
necessarily mean that they're devoid of
nutrition. So for example, one tablespoon
of olive oil provides 13% and 7% of your
daily vitamin E and K needs, respectively.
As well, they do facilitate the
absorption of fat soluble vitamins.
And yes of course eating whole foods that
are high in fat can also help with this
but to vilify oil and make a blanket
statement that all oils are bad just
it's not fair or true. There are
definitely oils that are overly
processed without a doubt but opting for
healthier oil like cold-pressed extra
virgin olive oil is totally completely
fine in moderation. Again, you can of
course be mindful of serving sizes, I'm
not telling you to go drink a bottle of
olive oil, but we don't necessarily need
to demonize it or eliminate it either. So
while I can totally respect that Derek
chooses to get his fats from a whole
food diet, there's no reason not to
include a little bit of oil and
personally, I just think this is an
overly restrictive food rule that can
interfere with a lot of social aspects
of eating and food. Besides that, it is
clear to me that Derek makes sure to
avoid making any substantial nutrition
claims and really focuses his time on
sharing delicious vegan meals and
recipes that fuel his body. To me, I think
that Derek, very much likes shows like
game-changers, is really great evidence
that you can 100% be vegan and maintain
and build muscle. So kudos to that. So I
just want to finish off mentioning some
of my favorite takeaways from Derek's
channel. Number one, lots of delicious,
easy, and balanced recipes. While the
veggie chopping is probably too
cumbersome for most people, at least his
recipes are simple to follow enough for
people at home. Number two he's a great
example that vegans can build muscle too
because I'm sure that you are all sick
of people asking you
"hey where do you get your protein?". And
number three, he doesn't seem to be pushy
about his vegan lifestyle or giving
nutrition advice. Bottom line, I truly
enjoyed exploring Derek's Channel. I'm
actually a huge fan of his positive
personality and approach to life and
it's really fun to watch more awesome
male youtubers in the Wellness space. His
meals are simple to follow, nutrient
dense, and most importantly look really
delicious. I am definitely a fan and I'm
gonna be watching a lot more for some
recipe inspiration. Well folks that is
all for today. Thanks again to Function
of Beauty for sponsoring this video. If
you liked it be sure to give it a thumbs
up, leave me a comment below with who you
would like to see review next,
subscribe to my channel, and I will see
you next time on Abbey's Kitchen. Bye!